.
LITERALLY STEALING GAS IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
HOW THOROUGHLY HAS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION MISMANAGED
AMERICAN LEADERSHIP AROUND THE
WORLD?
HERE IS ONE VERY SIGNIFICANT
ONE, SAUDI ARABIA REPORTEDLY
ACCEPTING CHINESE CURRENCY
INSTEAD OF U.S. DOLLARS FOR ITS
OIL SALES TO CHINA.
THEY SHOULD BE A HUGE CHANGE FOR
ALMOST 50 YEARS.
SAUDI ARABIA HAS NOT TRADED OIL
IN U.S. DOLLARS.
THAT HAS MASSIVE BOOM TO THE
UNITED STATES.
ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" WHO
WROTE THE STORY, THEY ARE
OFFERING EVERYTHING IMAGINABLE
TO THE SAUDIS.
WHAT WOULD THIS MEAN FOR THE
UNITED STATES?
A FORMER PENTAGON OFFICIAL AND
ALSO PRINCIPAL AT THE MARATHON
INITIATIVE.
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU JOIN
US.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
WE DIDN'T WANT TO LET THE STORY
PASS YOUR TO THINK IT IS IGNORED
BY A LOT OF PEOPLE.
IT SEEMS LIKE A MAJOR STORY TO
US, IS IT?
>> YEAH, I THINK SO, TUCKER.
YOU ARE RIGHT TO POINT TO THE
DOLLAR AND A CENTRAL WELL-BEING
AT A PRACTICAL LEVEL.
AND I THINK WE ARE SEEING EARLY
INDICATIONS OF MOVEMENT TOWARDS
PROBABLY TWO BLOCKS.
ONE LED BY US AND ONE LED BY
CHINA.
THAT IS GOING TO HAVE MASSIVE
IMPLICATIONS, ESPECIALLY FOR
POORLY ORGANIZED.
THE POINT YOU'RE MAKING, TUCKER,
WE NEED TO BE JEALOUSLY AND
CAREFULLY THINKING ABOUT THIS
KIND OF "CROWN JEWEL" OF THE
RULE OF THE DOLLAR.
JUST BEING CAREFUL HOW WE USE
IT.
THE SAUDIS ARE A GREAT EXAMPLE
OF POOR FORESIGHT AND STRATEGIC
PLANNING.
THE ADMINISTRATION WAS TOUGH ON
THE SAUDIS AND THE MURDER OF --
WAS AN ABOMINATION BUT ON THE
OTHER HAND, IF YOU ASK FOR HELP
MAY BE YOU SHOULD THINK ABOUT
HOW YOU APPROACH THEM IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
THIS IS NOT THE ONLY EXAMPLE
WHERE WE NEED TO TAKE A
STRATEGIC ACCOUNT OF THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE NOT SOLELY
FOCUS ON SORT OF MORAL
POSTURING, IF YOU WILL.
THAT IS A CLASSIC EXAMPLE.
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW OTHERWISE WE
WILL NOT THINK LONG-TERM
INTEREST OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: IT FEELS LIKE
COLLEGE SOPHOMORE AND ALL THEY
ARE CAPABLE IS A MORAL LECTURE.
I'M NOT AGAINST MORALIZING, WE
DO IT ALL THE TIME AND THERE ARE
MORAL QUESTIONS TO SOLVE.
IF YOU ARE LEAPING A COUNTRY,
SHOULDN'T YOU PUT INTEREST AT
THE TOP OF THE CONCERNS?
THEY DON'T SEEM TO BE.
>> ABSOLUTELY COME I THINK YOU
DO.
YOU TAKE PROPER ACCOUNT OF THE
WAYS IN WHICH YOU PURSUE
HIGH-MINDED GOALS.
YOU STICK TO THEM.
IF YOU MAKE A HUGE MORAL ISSUE
AND BACK OFF A BIT WHEN YOU NEED
IT, THAT WILL RESULT THE SAUDIS
AND THEY WILL NOT RETURN YOUR
PHONE CALL.
THAT IS NOT SERVING A MORAL
INTEREST AND IT'S NOT SERVING
AMERICA'S INTEREST.
WE WENT THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
WE ARE A FORCE IN THE WORLD
BECAUSE WE ARE RICH AND CAN
AFFORD TO BE.
BUT THEY ARE NOT RICH IF WE ARE.
SO IF WE'D CHIP JEOPARDIZE
AFFLUENCE, WE JEOPARDIZE TO MAKE